we talked about her stupid outfit
i looked like trans chucky yeah we
designed we designed the studio last
year
did we get a picture of her outfit at
the wedding it was absolutely insane i
was also kind of in indian face i had um
uh uh self tanner on and it was like
peeling off of my neck and we didn't
notice until later when we looked at the
photos oh yeah i'm sorry i didn't get
past the hair i didn't understand what
was happening i was like this is a 39
year old woman no you you you have a
good uh reason for doing that hair yeah
and i also think that like you're
someone that i really do think about did
i did i do you like yeah how do you feel
that way like like
how do you feel do you see why i called
him out on his compliment because he'll
be like you had a really good
point about that or did you no you
didn't compliment and then he'll take it
back to me but i just can't say yeah can
i say the thing i asked you why are you
doing the stuff with the hair yeah and
you said that you know it's tough times
during covid yeah and you were just
telling um some of the people who work
with you and do some of your like
styling like hair stuff you're like
what's the most expensive procedure you
can do do it procedure okay easy what is
it called
like um hair uh style you basically were
like i want to put money in people's
pockets without just giving it to them a
lot of my friends were losing their jobs
because they were hair stylists they
were makeup artists you know what i mean
because in the beginning if you worked
within proximities of other people it
was like people were moving home losing
their insurance i'm an american hero
it's fine and um
i was like can i do this through my core
can we start up an llc for you thanks so
much and then i just started getting
lots of likes and so
after that it just became more that but
um but also it's like i think that
during the pandemic if you didn't go a
little crazy or i was kind of like
entertainers are supposed to entertain
i'm not gonna do zoom shows i'm gonna
keep doing stand-up and i want every
time someone sees my page i'm not gonna
be like hey guys i'm so depressed during
the pa i'm just gonna be like here's my
[ __ ] blue hair here's
you know i mean roast me make fun of me
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm an entertainer
first yeah i hear you
what you're looking for something else
there's i'm not looking for anything
else you get a little bit addicted to it
because people um don't talk to you in
public when you have you're a woman and
you have blue hair people like oh [ __ ]
like she's going through something like
the curve episode where larry put on the
mega head yes yes no one asks you to
like watch their kids no
it's like kind of great you do have to
deal with people like texting you every
now and then like are you okay but
that's fine
i did have to i did have to make sure if
you're okay a couple times yeah yeah i
did but what happens to when you guys
see a girl have pink hair blue hair what
happens you just think that you use it
well it's not just crazy i just think
dude it's it's a lot to maintain i
actually judge their fathers
okay
okay
you're like just call your dad i'm like
he [ __ ] up somehow he there's a if you
trace this all the way back okay so if
you see a girl with like blue hair
you're just like this person's broken
yeah yeah yeah if you upstream it it all
starts at the dead okay got it got it i
mean
the safest way you can reinvent yourself
dye your hair dye your hair now do you
think that that's sexist
that we chalk up a woman's behavior only
to the dad as if the mom can make no
effect whatsoever because i think the
reverse sexism happens all the time with
you guys where it's like if someone's a
serial killer like well the mom must not
have let him wear her pantyhose
you know what i mean
so it's always a guy's fault norman
bates psycho so wait are all serial
killers trans but they're not out well
no did you see mine hunter the um is
that what you just said as a statement
no there's did you make that statement
on flagrant oh my god no but we're going
to get the ted bundy clip back up
give me a bite
zuckerberg if i'm in it it'll stay up
just let me finish okay go go go go go
go i can sanitize this joke go if they
take a woman down they're silencing a
woman and i can accuse jeff of rape oh
wow
who's jeff zuckerberg is that his first
name
zuckerberg bezos oh [ __ ] i could i
he
mark
i went to jeffrey kadzenberg
i was sad i'm submitting hold on
my boyfriend's gay
[Laughter]
how can i be anti-semitic my dude is a
jew